bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors le port du masque est
donc obligatoire depuis à plusieurs
semaines dès l'âge de 6 ans à l'école
c'est une mesure que vous jugé
disproportionné pourquoi alors pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que la
manière dont cet article 36 a été pris
nous paraît un petit peu hâtive et il
n'y a pas eu de publication des données
scientifiques disponibles de ce qu'on
appelle l'étude d'impact qui est bien
sûr nécessaire en matière de santé
publique et surtout parce que la
différence des autres couples qui ont pu
être formé juste au moment où cette
mesure avait été prise nous nous avons
là plusieurs semaines d'expérience et
donc on a cette expérience acquise par
les parents mais également par les
scientifiques qui nous montre que le
préjudice qui semble être causés aux
enfants par est plus grand que le risque
épidémique réel si tenté qu'il soit
celui là démontrer et puis on a aussi
des parents qui ont pu nous expliquer
que leurs enfants se sont retrouvés à la
porte de l'école alors là on arrive dans
des situations qui sont encore plus
graves ou des élèves sont privés de
l'instruction qui l'aurait qui doit leur
être dispensés parce que pour une raison
de santé ou autres ils ne peuvent pas
porter le masque et donc pour toutes ces
raisons
au regard du contexte général on a
considéré que
on pouvait agir pour contester la
légalité de ce décret alors vous avez
consulté des professionnels de santé à
ce sujet à quelles sont les conséquences
du port de masques sur sur les écoliers
d'après eux
alors nous on a pu constater on essayait
de se référer à plusieurs études à
plusieurs spécialistes en france mais
également il ya d étude danoise
notamment très importante sur justement
les les dommages que peut causer le
masque alors le masque d'abord chez ces
enfants si jeunes il pose le problème
lui-même d'être admis à microbes
parce que des enfants de 6 7 ans ne
peuvent pas s'empêcher de justement
touché ce masque en permanence et on se
pose la question de savoir si ce nid à
microbes en permanence sur sur le visage
des enfants justement n'était pas source
de contamination mais plus grave on a
des cas d'hypoxie des enfants qui ont du
mal à respirer
d'autres qu'ils le soient rentrés en
ayant très très mal à la tête par
exemple ce matin une maman ne racontais
que depuis que le masque est imposé sa
fille avait très très mal à la tête et
on s'est rendu compte que c'est parce
qu'elle a des lunettes d'habitude
donc ils sont imposés et que comme quand
elle mettait le masque et ses lunettes
et die avait d'abus et sur ses lunettes
la maîtresse lui a dit de ne plus porter
cellule est donc ça faisait deux
semaines que ne portait plus ses
lunettes en ayant des migraines très
très fort donc après chaque cas est
différent mais on se rend compte outre
en plus le traumatisme quand même dedans
sans jeunes qui nous ont envoyé des
dessins on voyait vraiment que le masque
était considéré comme un danger voir un
ami
et ça ça nous a beaucoup interpellé
puisqu'il s'agit d'un accessoire quand
même somme toute banale mais pour eux
pas du tout banal et en plus les réels
risquent d'avoir toute la journée sur le
visage en permanence en un buteur ce
morceau de tissu
alors ce recours s'appuie sur le
principe de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant issu de la convention des
droits de l'enfant adoptée ya 31 ans par
l'assemblée générale de l'onu vous
pensez que ce principe doit prévaloir
sur les mesures de santé publique
imposée à la
population générale et est ce que vous
pensez que justement ce recours pour
faire reculer le gouvernement français
puis le faire revenir sur cette mesure
alors que l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant doivent primer en matière de
décisions administratives non seulement
je le pense mais c'est aussi l'état du
droit
aujourd'hui en france et
l'interprétation qu'en fait notamment le
conseil d'état c'est que l'article 3
justement la convention new york sur les
droits de l'enfant impose que l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant doit être pris en
compte pour toute décision
administrative
donc ça c'est le premier point c'est
l'état du droit on ne peut pas prendre
une décision administrative si cette
décision viole l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant
après faire le reculer le gouvernement
j'aimerais surtout que le gouvernement
et les équipes ministérielles qui
travaillent sur ces textes donnent
l'impression aux français d'avoir
travaillé de manière approfondie sur les
mesures qui sont prises parce qu'on a
quand même un sentiment d'amateurisme et
de manque de transparence et c'est le
nid à tous les complots tease les tous
les fantasmes donc nous ce qu'on
voudrait surtout c'est que quand il
s'agit de toucher aux libertés est
d'autant plus les libertés des enfants
et bien à tout le moins que en euro on
donne les éléments qui auraient pu
guider une telle décision mais il me
semble que ces éléments n'existent pas
en fait
eh bien ce sera ce sera le mot de la fin
karine shebab au merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocate et membre du collectif à
l'origine du recours donc auprès du
conseil d'état merci beaucoup